Stars, galaxy, in astral seas abound, on cosmic paths we'll trace, where wings, liberty, is such a wondrous thing, behind us of rumsy, come take your place, we're leaving soon for, sure it's the right place, yes, absolutely, once said distinctly, a favern of the dark that smokes, in oil, trees of Antares, a bar, see my finest quality lettuce, direct from the lush gardens of Andromeda,
Talking birds, all languages, jumping monkeys, exotic rare, huh?
Just down there.
Absolutely sure.
Yes, you bet.
You know where it is.
Worry.
Here we are.
You have a reputation as a good informant, Clark, so we're going along with you on it.
It's a hard thing to believe all the same.
I mean mercenaries operating right here on Omega.
I'm surprised.
He's late.
Stop all this dawdling.
For your information, young man, I am not dawdling.
I am acquiring additional data, and I must say, your world is most curious and, alas, illogical.
Buddy, how about a drink for your old pa-
Sorry.
I think you need rewiring.
This animal drink?
Animal yourself, stupid.
No, he doesn't drink, but I do, and I can out-drink anybody here.
Look, over there, there's one of them.
Hey, buddy, how about a drink?
Eh, sorry.
Hey, over here.
That's the other one, over there.
Okay, so I can understand.
Can you tune in on what they're saying, Metro?
I'm under the impression that's what I'm here for.
All of them live in caves.
They hunt animals with no more than sticks of wood, you realize?
Looks to me like it's a pretty hairy scene, savages.
Yeah, and in all this, we're supposed to do what?
First, you say we set up a base and reinforcements land, and from then on...
We'll conquer the planet, can't miss.
And who'll we be doing all this for, I'd like to know.
It's not healthy to be asking too many questions or know too much.
We get good money, and with these weapons we've got, we'll be...
Sure, it's good money. Only a mercenary likes to know who's paying him.
Hold it. Contact just showed up.
What's wrong, Metro?
Patience, young man. I am phasing interference into my frequency.
That should keep my colleague there from detecting my listening activity.
That's it.
For his record, you're lucky to get him very well.
In two days, precisely at moonrise, a spaceship will come to pick you up at that time.
Give the signal, Joe. Go ahead.
You too. It was a mistake.
No, no, I swear.
No.
Please give us a replay of that, son.
First, we'll determine the exact planet in question.
Project information on planets inhabited by creatures in basic developmental stage, hunting animals with wooden pikes.
Planet Larissa, in the constellation of the Great Bear.
Distance, 23,377,400 light years.
It is one of the most curious planets in spiral galaxy M101.
Humanoid life is little evolved, chiefly based on hunting and gathering.
Planet closed to all visitors.
It wouldn't be that one, now.
Nersi, small planet on the outer edge of spherical star cluster M13 in the constellation of Hercules.
Cluster comprises 300,000 stars and has a diameter of 23 minutes of arc or 25,000 light years.
A liquid crystal atmosphere lethal to humans.
A form of life does exist, well evolved and adapted to the atmosphere.
Planet closed to visitors.
Loneida, in the constellation of the triangle, medium-sized planet in spiral galaxy M33.
Distance, 2 million light years.
A highly elliptical orbit around its sun results in a cycle of killing cold followed by intense heat.
These conditions make any highly evolved life unlikely.
Planet closed to visitors.
No, no, no. Surely it is not them.
The sentence also says they live in caves. Surely we all agree that they are not cave dwellers.
We aren't terribly sure of how they live, Matro. He could mean in a sort of burrow or grotto.
Well, it appears to have become rather pedantic, my lad.
I think it's time to do a little modification on your circuits. You lack humility.
Don't give me that my lad business, my lad. I am above all that.
Oh, humility indeed with the example that you're always setting.
He talks to me like that. He dares to?
Planet Clarus in star cluster NGC 752.
I think we might eliminate that planet now, since our recent visit.
The spiral galaxy of Andromeda M31.
400 billion stars, planet Diane.
Distance 2 million light years.
Atmosphere suitable for human life.
Primitive inhabitants under long-term observation.
Approximately 20,000 years required before achieving sufficiently high level to join Confederation.
Looks like one of my ancestors.
Well, well, well, you really are old.
Yes, that looks right.
That's enough. I think this is it.
Recording again?
Creatures and all of them live in caves.
They hunt animals more than sticks of wood.
It would appear that once more the invasion of another planet is in preparation.
The colonel recommends using a massive force of intervention.
I'm in full agreement, but for the present we have no idea who's behind it.
That's the initial question.
The investigation is underway, but whoever it is, I think we must take immediate action.
And if it is a member of our confederation, it is quite a serious matter and should be sent to the Grand Council.
That's the difficult part.
We are obliged to take into consideration all the many conflicting interests of all of them.
It will be very difficult to obtain a majority of the council in favor of immediate action,
and the potential aggressors should know our intentions and act accordingly.
Within my authority, I can maintain secrecy in all our operations of limited scope.
But the Colonel wants much more.
In view of your loyalty to the Confederation, I should like to have your opinions, gentlemen.
Well, in my judgment, it ought to remain a police operation.
And if they arrive in full force, what will we look like then?
Yes, of course you're right.
Then we all agree, it is to be a large-scale police action.
What we need is the battleship that I've been dreaming about for years.
It would have been a real pleasure hitting them over the head with heavy cruisers.
Now don't you worry. We'll take care of them with what we've got.
Come in, gentlemen.
It's all yours.
This will be a surveillance defense mission.
You are to protect the planet Diane from foreign invasion.
Cruisers Kangaroo, Cobra, Grass Snake will take part in the operation
and are placed under the orders of Captains Elstrom, Agar, and Malva.
The Hummingbird is my ship.
Lightships Dragonfly and Spider under the orders of Peter Jr. and Gross Jr.
will be responsible for the close surveillance
and making contact to acquire information.
These are your orders.
On the way to the objective, we fly in formation.
Immediate departure.
That's all, gentlemen.
Good job.
Think so?
Spider, all systems are go here.
Lieutenant.
Seconds, hyperspace speed.
Never seen anything like hyperspace.
Fantastic.
Turning to normal space in a few seconds.
Stand by.
Galaxy N31 in Andromeda.
Good old dragonfly.
She's really tremendous.
Had major repairs, and now she's good as new.
Ships under my orders.
Stand by and hear this:
We are entering the gravitational field of the planet Diane's sun.
Trace an elliptical orbit to escape it.
Our objective is in sight.
Kangaroo, cobra, grass snake, with me.
In a stationary orbit above the stratosphere.
Try and find natural cover, a meteor or a large rock mass.
Keep as hidden as possible.
Now your youngsters.
Spider, close observation.
Dragonfly, terrain investigate.
Anyway, weapons unless absolutely necessary.
Stood?
Order is understood.
Right there!
That's where we can land the ship.
Flight!
The inhabitants here live as our ancestors did 20,000 years ago.
Well, let's have a look.
We've been walking for hours and haven't met anybody yet.
Yet flying over, we spotted several fires around here.
Conditions aren't very conducive for supporting life.
In the Cro-Magnon days, the total population was about what it is in one city.
On a chance, you might hit one of them.
You don't mean you speak your language.
No, of course not.
His heart's still beating.
Is a mighty hunter and the worthiest of men.
So his name is Apar.
We know that much.
What's he going on about?
He says his father was a great chief, respected by all.
The day he died was a sad one.
It's me!
Understand me!
Nobody else!
Prostrate yourself before your chief!
Ha ha ha!
Chief and his men were out hunting.
Par defied the great god bear to show to all that he was a great hunter.
Now I'm beginning to understand.
Just like in the film.
Par, is it exact?
His name is Domine.
He's a wise man and sorcerer.
He was a high priest in the days of Apar's father, respected by all.
Oh, I'd give a lot to be able to talk with.
You speak the old language. That's excellent.
I've heard how both of you helped in the hunt.
Just in case you're a bit surprised, I talk your language.
Well, I'm a sorcerer. Who can explain it? Yes.
But our idiot leader thinks that I'm crazy.
But don't you worry. There is going to be a change around here soon, I swear it.
Now tell exactly is it that you come from.
Planet Omega. Two million light years distant from here.
Andromeda is here.
And to the east?
Two million light years. That's quite a walker.
Right to the east? That's Scorpio.
Oh, that's Virgo.
Yo, and Cancer, and Gemini.
What did you learn about all that?
My good man, our ancestors knew a great deal. Nothing is really new.
All I do is pass on the information that was passed on to me by the sky beings during their visit here.
I assure you, their quantity of knowledge was immense.
They knew how to heat minerals to render them malleable and shape all sorts of objects.
They invented instruments to measure time and space.
They could make words permanent in writing.
And they were able to lift enormous weights and rise themselves in the air.
Who were they? Where were they from?
Where did they go?
That's it. That's it.
Wait, wait, wait. An old legend has it that long ago, a great coldness descended upon our planet and nearly everyone.
One day they arrived, like you, from a distant planet, cut off from their own world, and they settled here.
For a long time, their memory was revered as if they were gods, and then in time, little by little, they were forgotten.
I think I'm the last to remember them.
Pretty, isn't she?
Well, I'll fire it in the kiln tomorrow, tonight.
Too tired, knowing so much what's the point in the end.
Rejoin my ancestors.
Grow old, I bid you all.
Back in time in antiquity,
Plato spoke about an alien civilization brought to Earth people by gods from outer space.
The idea goes back a long time.
Yes, it's true.
Only there have been certain other cultures and even some religions
who have always denied this myth of two-legged gods coming to infuse a new civilization.
Curious all the same.
No, I'd be happy if you would call me by my first name.
Call me Peter, and you are Yana.
Okay, I'm Peter. It's me, and your name's Yana.
Me, Peter? Your name Yana, right?
No, I'm Peter, understand?
And you are Yana.
No, we're not. We're only friends.
That'd be good, Peter.
Well, one day can be married to Yana.
Who knows?
Since then, you've never had any more visits from outer space?
No, no, not really.
Every so often, we sight a UFO, an unidentified flying object, as we call them.
Whenever we spot one, I'm in favor of transmitting a signal,
but the chief forbids it, that imbecile.
He says they must be evil spirits.
Well, what do you know?
There he comes, our illustrious great chief.
There, that's him.
You dumb twit again.
You were wrong at your lousy predictions about the hunt.
I'm just going to mess up with a mug, you know that?
It would help if you didn't sneeze all the time and scare away the game.
How are we going to feed everyone, huh?
Tell me, saying yes, chief.
Yes, chief.
Hey, my holders, who killed that animal?
Extinct still behind you.
I don't suppose you would know.
Come from a...
You're plotting against me with that power.
I know it.
Then surround them.
You use my one, and you're going to be his.
You understand that?
I guess that's the sign he likes you.
So you say you come from the sky, stupid.
In that case, prove it to me, and quick, mother, put you in a...
That's how it is.
I'll prove to you who we are.
Great-spirited one, calling the one out in the sky.
Spirited...
hears me. Oh hear my call, oh ye great spirit, come on, I'm waiting. The great spirit, where
are you when we need you? What's all that jazz? What's this great spirit routine? I don't
get it. They're in trouble, that's it. They're in danger, but they mention our name. There's
no time to lose. There, it won't take long. Stan, you just sent a message to the spirit
in the sky, eh? Send a victim away. The evil spirit, shoot. My little statue, nothing new
like you. Good. I go with you. No, Yana. Your life is here with your people. Apar will be a good
husband, and he'll be a great leader for your tribe. You must elevate your society to be truly
human. Banish all forces of brutality and injustice. Learn to respect and love each other,
regardless of any difference. And you must work to achieve real progress. Then one day,
you will be able to join the community of those who live in the sky, and that day will return.
My statue.
This is Grass Snake. This is Grass Snake.
Formation of eight combat ships bearing toward you.
Awaiting orders.
This is Hummingbird.
Cobra and kangaroo in formation.
Grass Snake, prepare to attack from the rear.
Here we go.
Interstellar police calling.
Who are you?
Identify yourself in five seconds or we open fire.
Four, three, two, one.
I don't think we'll be seeing them again soon.
But as a precaution, we'll set some space mines.
Wait a second.
Any news from Dragonfly?
This is Dragonfly.
this is dragonfly with spider we are rejoining formation nothing to report
sometime later say goodbye to daddy and a good hunt one day young handsome gods
came down from the sky and they were dressed in clothing made of light yes
and they brought knowledge to our world but there were evil ones among us here
and so you're such a one